who was the hardest quarterback to
tackle Lamar is crazy bro I was gonna
say Lamar is Shifty when I played
English tomorrow last year had him on
his shoulder and he like kind of jumped
out I was like bro this is crazy bro
who's the hardest quarterback for you
yeah obviously you got to put Lamar in
that conversation Russell Wilson when he
was with the Seattle Seahawks nobody
wanted to play Russell Wilson he would
run around they run around again run
around find an open guy and like hit him
bro like Kyla Mary Tyler broke out of
one of my sacks I don't know how
literally grabbed both his shoulder pads
and he like squatted and slid out and
made a play and I was sick I think Tyler
is tough and I think Josh Allen he was
my first Career College side it was a
half sack but I still counted and he was
at Wyoming and that dude like dragged me
for three yards I'm like okay this
dude's a monster